[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
christiane emmanuel bonjour à tous les
auditeurs de nantes et les premières et
bonjour à tous les martiniquais
vous êtes une artiste influent précisé
vous êtes danseuse professeur de danse
chorégraphe et vous avez été aussi à
l'initiative on le rappelle de la maison
rouge un lieu de résidence d'artistes
qui se trouve à fort-de-france au
quartier des terres sainville et qui
fonctionne à l'heure où on parle mais
vous êtes invités aujourd'hui que les
siens emmanuel en tant que présidente de
la commission culture identité
patrimoine de l'assemblée de martinique
en la ctn la collectivité territoriale
de martinique et nous allons avec vous
faire un bilan bon forcément partielle
dans ce domaine de la mandature qui est
sur le point de s'achever
alors vous même là c'était elle a tiré
son bilan y compris dans le domaine de
la culture et de la valorisation de
notre patrimoine
et vous parlez d'un investissement qui
s'anime à tuer emmanuel matériel et
immatériel incalculable consacré au
patrimoine et à la culture au cours de
ces cinq années et demie vous ajoutez
même aucune mandature n'a consacré
autant d'efforts en gros vous il n'y a
pas eu deux nuls autres pareils quoi
c'est un bilan nul autre pareil allant
qu'est ce qui peut vous pousser quand
même une telle forme d'autosatisfaction
et comment argumenter vous cette
affirmation alors très souvent est
effectivement lors des bilans de
certaines mandature j'entendais en tant
que
danseuse enfin tant que martiniquaise
oui nous n'avons pas eu le temps de
terminer tous les projets en une amende
atur nous ne pouvons pas terminer tous
les projets bon c'était sans compter
avec mon énergie pour cette nouvelle
mandature et aussi cette complicité
entre madame marie hélène les oatei mois
et surtout une administration vraiment
qui depuis des années s'occupe de la
culture
donc ça a été relativement je vais pas
dire simples mais relativement rapides à
mettre les choses en place à réfléchir
ensemble à poser les bonnes questions et
aller de l'avant
donc effectivement
2-3 exemple il ya eu l'installation du
musée du père pinchon qui a été un
projet de l'ain de la mandature de
monsieur marie jeanne et qui n'a pas eu
le temps de se mettre en place
la dernière il a maintenant donc il ya
eu le père pêchant il ya fonds
saint-jacques et à tivoli
il y a comme un dirigeant fait il ya
quelques jeunes et voilà il ya plusieurs
exemples s'arrêter sur quelques exemples
parce qu'ils vont également en dix
minutes on peut pas faire le catalogue
de tout ce qui a été fait parce qu'il ya
des choses à me réalisée il ya des
choses qui sont en cours et puis ya des
choses qui n'ont pu être aussi réalisé
bien bien évidemment voilà même si vous
estimez que l'ensemble du programme a
quand même été a pu être effectivement
et effectué quelques exemples notamment
vous mettez en avant l'école
martiniquaise de l'enseignement des arts
l'emea
oui alors l'emea c'est comme c'est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
conservatoire mais nous ne sommes pas
vraiment nous ne sommes pas dans cette
dynamique de conserver trois donc nous
avons choisi de territorialiser
l'enseignement artistique avec les
associations qui existent sur le
territoire martiniquais et qui font déjà
le job c'est à dire que à mon retour ça
fait 34 ans que je suis revenu dans mon
amante inique et personnellement j'ai
participé en tant que pédagogue à cinq
ou six tentatives ou d'études et de
tentatives de mise en place deux d'école
labellisés ou pas et cela ça n'a jamais
marché et à certains projets qui sont
restés dans les tiroirs dans cette fois
ci en analysant ce qui s'est passé et en
même temps le nombre d'artistes qui sont
rentrés diplômés pour enseigner dans ces
écoles plus ou moins fantôme ils sont là
ils sont sur le territoire ils font
leurs effectifs oui cet effectif
oui nous avions signé nous avons fini en
2018 une convention avec le ministère de
la culture et donc nous avons commencé
par labelliser les écoles de musique
donc nous avons choisi trois sur le
territoire pour le moment pour la
première étape la deuxième étape c'est
au fur et à mesure que nous allons faire
entrer c'est un projet extrêmement
délicat délicat et important pour nous
donc nous allons vraiment au fur et à
mesure en analysant les possibilités
parce que ce qu'est ce qu'il faut de
véritables pédagogue pas des artistes
qui gratte la guitare ou qui savent
chanter non nous voulons des artistes
certes des enseignants certes mais aussi
qu'ils ont un contenu pédagogique
alors quand il est artiste quand il est
créateur et pédagogue c'est très bien
mais nous avons besoin de véritable
pédagogue pour pouvoir poursuivre son
projet donc là nous avons labelliser les
écoles de dans les écoles de musique
nous allons sur les écoles de danse là
ça va aller à six écoles de martinique
six associations qui seront labellisés
nous sommes en contact avec tous les
mois maire du grand nord pour développer
tous les maires du nord ont accepté de
travailler avec nous et là le théâtre
vont terminer rapidement le théâtre ces
tropiques atrium qui
et s'en occupe et qui le fait très bien
sa formation ce moment alors il ya des
formations et surtout je veux dire qu'il
ya après les formations nos tropiques
atrium il y à dd des martiniquais et
même des non martiniquais qui était en
stage à tropiques atrium qui sont dans
grandes écoles et il ya une j'oublie le
pré son nom mais ils on a une jeune
martiniquaise qui a fait tropiques
atrium et qui est maintenant au
conservatoire supérieur national de
théâtre alors on peut également signaler
le campus caribéen des arts un kiwi
royal et de ses cendres voilà on va pas
s'étendre
voilà je voudrais qu'on insiste un petit
peu sur la fin des travaux au domaine de
fonds saint-jacques pas aussi j'ai un
salve à la fois une dimension culturelle
et patrimoniale
un site qui est fermé depuis la fin de
l'année 2017 alors vous indiquer qu'il a
été réhabilité pour un montant d'un
million 4 mai un peu plus de trois ans
après sa fermeture toujours pas
fonctionnel et opérationnel
c'est là de toutes les façons dans très
peu de temps nous allons refaire
remonté le personnel à fond saint
jacques l'inauguration je ne sais pas
quand est-ce qu'elle va se faire mais
déjà prendre possession du lieu
surtout que les habitants singer 6
millions d'ici deux ou trois semaines
nous allons avoir la livraison de
chantier alors pourquoi ce retard je
vais vous dire c'est un projet les
dernières réparations de fonds saint
jacques ont été opérés en 2010 nous
arrivons en 2016 et les réparations
les travaux sont en état donc nous avons
décidé le temps de rechercher des
documents de voir comment quel projet
ils avaient d'analysé de voir la
faisabilité de récupérer les 700000
euros du ministère de la culture parce
que nous allions les perdre parce que
c'est un budget qui avait été votée en
2010 et en 2015 il fallait faire
plusieurs reports époux alors
d'augmenter un peu caustique là c'était
un peu compliqué mais autre chose très
importante
alors que fonds saint-jacques avait déjà
subi une première vague de travaux les
murs n'ont jamais été analysés donc
quand nous arrivons fin prêt pour
démarrer les travaux en 2017 et belle
fallait des amiantés
c'est à dire qu'en 2010 le travail
n'avait pas été fait donc en 2017 nous
avons commencé par des amiantés et au
fur et à mesure accompagnée nous avons
aussi comment dirais-je la chapelle donc
il faut suivre aussi les comment
dirais-je les préconisations du
ministère de la culture comme ça sans
talons parce qu'il y avait des
complications avec déduplication
récession tout mais j'avais le dire
aussi
nous avons eu à payer des factures de
2008 qui n'était pas payée de certaines
personnes qui ont dit qu'ils avaient eu
l'ailé comment dirais-je cave qui ont eu
le manche est et au fur et à mesure ils
nous sortait les factures donc le train
de chercher et tout est bloqué sa pub ça
pouvait bloquer les travaux
mais voilà d'ici deux à trois semaines
nous rentrons dans fonds saint-jacques
donc alors bien un projet pour fonds
saint-jacques également de valorisation
de réhabilitation d'un cimetière
d'esclaves d'un ossuaire de femmes et
hommes déportés en esclavage
en martinique on va dire ça comme ça
c'est toujours
d'actualité c'est valable qu est-ce qu
alors je vais juste dire aux artistes
qu'il y a des chambres ça sera un espace
de résidences d'artistes ya des chambres
aménagées et cuisiner tout pour recevoir
des artistes parce que fonds
saint-jacques doit être aussi un lieu de
fabrique
alors vous vous revenir au cimetière
d'esclaves
effectivement ça sera l'un des projets
majeurs de deux nouveaux directeurs de
fonds saint jacques c'est à dire comment
comment comment directeur de fonds saint
jacques
non non non il est nommé 2000 2010 m6 a
su les oui laurent ursule et d'ailleurs
que je salue et qui est vraiment qui a
vraiment qui a été à l'écouté
c'est un très bon suivi de travaux et je
l'en remercie
et l'une des ddd sachs l'un des axes
majeurs de fonds saint-jacques ça sera
effectivement comment mettre en valeur
ce cimetière d'esclaves pour que ça soit
un lieu de mémoire un lieu de mémoire
est aussi un lieu de
deux rencontres et entre guillemets
j'espère que nous allons qu'ils vont
nous comprendre un lieu de connexion
avec ses ancêtres voilà que ça les
manuels ça passe très vite
c'est déjà terminé voilà on savait qu'on
ne pouvait pas faire le bilan de manière
exhaustive mais rollin voilà nous avons
évoqué quelques projets qui ont été
réalisés et puis d'autres qui sont en
perspective pour bientôt merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
bonne journée pour retrouver jimmy merci
au revoir
[Musique]